no matter how much research I do there's
always that one complaint in the
comments about me not knowing the
original source material so today I went
down into the depths and you know what
random commenter you were absolutely
right
there buried deep in the obscure
Forgotten lore was the answer I was
looking for the last Jedi is the name of
a Star Wars comic from 1981 so obviously
the plot of the new movie will be
clearly inspired from that so let's see
what Disney has in store for us in the
comic Luke and Leia traveled to a remote
planet to rescue a prince sounds
plausible and it's there that they meet
a brain-damaged bug man who carries a
stick like it's a lightsaber okay and
that guy's name is Jedediah so when he
dies Luke refers to him as the last Jedi
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that'll
tempt you to give in to your skepticism
and succumb to the dark side of your
favorite franchises doing so the last
Jedi is right around the corner the red
carpet world premiere is happening later
this week and you know what I have
something to prove I've already gone out
on a limb to make a prediction as to who
Ray's parents are but I think I could go
one step further this is my last chance
to prove to you that old team theorists
over here is digging deeper and looking
closer at the evidence than anyone else
out there and what better way to prove
that I'm worthy of my theory salt and by
predicting how this year's biggest
blockbuster is gonna play out before
anyone even gets to see it
that's right ladies and gentlemen before
anyone in the world sees this movie I am
gonna call the major twists of Star Wars
the last Jedi based on trailer analysis
and good old-fashioned research and to
make things a little more interesting
let's put some stakes on it if I'm right
then you have to subscribe to this
channel come back to the film theorists
Channel and force push that subscribe
button and if I'm wrong I don't know
that's your side of the deal and let me
know what I should do in the comments
about the thing that you want to see me
do I'll see it we'll make it happen in a
future video it's only fair no weird
kinky stuff deal deal oh just assume
that you're making a handshake gesture
towards your computer screen right now
like I am like an idiot okay so if we're
sticking with the whole Star Wars rhymes
George Lucas quote thing then the last
Jedi will be the tense middle chapter
like The Empire Strikes Back at least I
hope it's the dark and surprising Empire
Strikes Back middle chapter and on the
slow-paced terrible dialog Attack of the
Clones middle chapter I don't like sand
by the hype director Rian Johnson is
giving his own movie we should expect
the unexpected
he's teased that moments of the movie
will quote shock the audience and that
one scene in particular will leave us
unable to breathe so it's my test today
to figure out how this movie is gonna
take our breaths away vader style
there's a lot we don't know I mean we
don't even know some of the character
names one of the new characters being
introduced to this movie is played by
Mini CEO del Toro but everyone has been
super tight-lipped about what his
character's name actually is it seems
awfully suspicious I mean officially
he's labeled as DJ but DJ yeah not
buying it nice try marketing people but
you expect me to believe that a badass
Star Wars character is gonna be named
after a teenage girl from full house
besides some do to gamestop already
determined that's toy version of this
character has a helmet inscription in or
Abeche that translates to don't join aka
DJ for short
my prediction this character is gonna be
the Lando Calrissian of this movie the
laid-back smooth talk and double-crosser
anyway that's just a random observation
get ready to get those sub fingers the
clickin because i've looked at all the
information I could find and I am
confident that I've got the ending of
the last Jedi figured out and Rian
Johnson is right it's now you know how
movies sometimes reveal a bit too much
from their trailers well I've now seen
the teaser and trailers for the last
Jedi more times than I've seen the Sun
in the past few months and I believe the
clues to the plot of the movies are
there in a few very important votes and
images let's start by reviewing the main
things that we see in here across the
Lucas training rayon Ock - but doesn't
seem too happy about it and might
actually quit leading us to important
quote number one
before that scared me enough that it
doesn't know he also has a major hot
take on the Jedi an important quote
number two I only know one truth time
for the Jedi to end over in kylo Ren
land we get a little monologue from
Snoke talking about how special he is an
important quote number three when I
found you kylo ren's philosophy about
his parents is pretty well summed up an
important quote number four and finally
Rey is feeling a bit lost herself and
based on the trailer seems to be asking
kylo Ren for help an important quote
number five I need someone to show me my
place in all this
as far as imagery in both the teaser and
the trailers we get a look at something
very rare in the Star Wars universe
books including one specific book with a
very mysterious symbol on it and lastly
we have an image of Snoke helping ray
achieve her yoga goals by forcing her
into a painful backbend these all might
seem like disparate pieces but there's a
pretty clear through line here although
the whole crew will absolutely be in the
last Jedi this is primarily a movie
about Rey Luke kylo Ren and the bonds
they form and more importantly the bonds
they break with each other
so let's start the deep dive predictions
with our og hero Luke Skywalker and what
we can expect from him obviously from
the trailers he has some help to give
Rey but it's not like she's gonna show
up and everything goes off without a
hitch the two luke quotes I mentioned
before gives us a strong indication of
prediction number one he will not finish
Rey's training much the same way that
Yoda was reluctant to Train Luke and
then never finished doing so in the
Empire Strikes Back as for why Luke
believes the Jedi need to end that
conclusion is probably connected to why
he's on Achtung
in the force awakens Han says that the
people who knew Luke believed he went
off in search of the first Jedi Temple
after kylo Ren turned on him and killed
his students people who know him best
figure when looking for the first Jedi
Temple well he found that first Jedi
Temple on octave and the reason he went
there is almost certainly to find the
books we see in the trailers that symbol
you see on the book is actually the Jedi
symbol meaning that these books are
almost certainly the ancient Jedi texts
known as the Journal of the Wills the
Journal of the Wills are basically a
source of ancient wisdom and history of
the galaxy you remember to root in way
and Bay's Melba's from rogue one well
they were known as the guardians of the
Wills so this isn't coming completely
out of nowhere
now well we don't have a ton of
information on what is inside the
Journal of the Wills there are two
quotes that could be useful to us the
first is from the novelization of the
force awakens which states quote first
comes the day then comes the night after
the darkness shines through the light
the difference they say is only made
right by resolving of grey through
refined Jedi sight solid rhyme scheme
their Jedi taking apart the poetry like
a tenth grader learning the fine works
of William Carlos Williams it's clear
this Jedi text is saying that the Jedi
need to refine their site to create grey
bringing the absolute dark side and
absolute light side together to bring
balance to the force which I gotta say I
am NOT opposed to I mean what good guy
doesn't also want to use force lightning
and now maybe you'll be able to and Luke
might believe he's the one to make this
happen based on another quote from the
journal of wills quote and in the time
of greatest despair there shall come a
savior and he shall be known as the son
of the sons now admittedly this quote is
non canon but Luke could easily be
considered the son of the sons given his
home planet of Tatooine as a giant ball
of sand and sadness governed by two hot
Suns if Luke believes in these
quotations he may believe both that his
mission isn't over and that it's his
task to bring together the darkness and
the light maybe even through his own
death which would of course make him
jeanna and before you point out that the
film's title in other languages points
to the word Jedi being plural keep in
mind that the director very directly
stated that Luke himself is in fact the
last Jedi and more importantly that it's
explicitly stated that Luke is the last
Jedi in the opening crawl of the force
awakens reading sometimes does prove
essential but there's also a clue that
Luke's decision for the Jedi to end
isn't one he's making passively he is
going out swinging in the international
version of the last Jedi's poster Luke
is no longer in the background but is
instead in the middle holding a
lightsaber now there have been a lot of
official Star Wars posters over the
years I've looked at them all but in
every single one if you're shown holding
a lightsaber you are going to be
involved in a big lightsaber battle
before the end of the movie sure seems
like Luke isn't gonna go down quietly
and based on the rest of that poster
means they'll probably end up fighting
kylo Ren towards the end of the film so
where does that leave Rey well as cagey
as everyone involved in the last Jedi
has been about giving things away
they've also given so many interviews
that we can start to piece a few things
together Daisy Ridley said at a panel in
April that she and Luke might not have
the perfect mentor-mentee relationship
and said specifically that quote it's
difficult to meet your heroes because
they might not be what you expect this
reinforces what I said earlier that it's
likely that Rey won't complete her
training with Luke and will end up going
off on her own if Rey recognizes the
power of the force but then also
realizes that the mystique of the Jedi
and Luke Skywalker can't or won't give
her the answers she's so desperate for
is it such a stretch to believe that she
turned to the dark side dun dun dun I
know I know that saying a Star Wars
character turns evil is basically my
whole shtick yes I was wrong about Luke
don't treat me like the matpat who cried
synth because this one seriously makes
all of the sense in a big interview with
Entertainment Weekly Daisy Ridley says
that quote the resistance isn't all that
much terrain implying that she could
likely be swayed away from it wouldn't a
logical place to turn be towards kylo
Ren especially if he ends up being
revealed to be her brother and let me
just say it I know people disagree with
me on the whole Rey as kylo
sister theory but I am sticking to it
especially since there is no chance that
Disney is letting her parents be Star
Wars Battlefront exclusive non force
using characters made by EA sorry for
all you Dell iDEN truthers out there and
yes I know when aftermath it says that
Luke left her behind on jakku but it
doesn't actually say who the parents are
specifically so the answer still has yet
to be decided meaning han and leia still
makes the most sense regardless already
made a video for that theory and
honestly it doesn't really matter for
today's theory from their first few
encounters in the force awakens kylo ren
says ray needs a teacher and then he can
be the one to show her the ways of the
force i could show you the ways of the
force if Ray's looking for a teacher she
knows where to find one director Rian
Johnson also gives what feels like a
pretty big hint in that same
Entertainment Weekly piece where he says
about Rey whoa you're going to meet
people who you think are gonna help but
don't and help is gonna come from
unexpected places and it sounds to me
like Ray goes to Luke searching for help
Luke ends up giving up on her and she's
left to turn to kylo Ren who is eager to
extend a helping hand this is all
further supported by this production
photo of Rey with kylo Ren in the
background she seems awfully calm
considering she's right in front of a
guy who tried to kill her in the last
movie but maybe you feel like this would
come out of nowhere that there's no hint
of the dark side near Rey at any point
well how about this
you remember that Snoke quote from
earlier about seeing raw power in kylo
Ren he's not talking about kylo Ren in
Taiwan the subtitles for that very same
trailer use a very specific character
for the pronoun you when Snoke says when
I found you and that character is
specifically feminine in the Taiwanese
language not a masculine usage so unless
there's some unexpected backstory on
kylo Ren Snoke is absolutely talking
about Ray when I found you gray and with
this reveal suddenly a lot of pieces
from the force awakens and the less Jedi
start falling into place
Snoke sends to Rey in the force when she
was very young
prompting her parents who may or may not
be Han and Leia along with Luke's help
to exile
somewhere where they thought she'd never
be found jakku so Snoke went after her
older brother Ben instead now that Snoke
has found ray remember that image of the
two of them from the trailer would it
really be that hard to turn her to the
dark side Adam driver says again in that
same Entertainment Weekly piece which
really revealed a lot that his character
kylo Ren began turning against his
parents because he felt they cared more
about the resistance than they cared
about him wouldn't that be enough to
turn rey against an idol who rejects her
and parents who abandoned her so here is
your shocking ending to this year's
biggest movie Rey's bad experience with
Luke coupled with a knowledge that she's
kylo Ren's sister leads her to ask kylo
to help her find my pace losses one way
or another ratios herself as open to the
dark side Luke comes to fight kylo Ren
and potentially Snoke as well thinking
he'll ever a on a side but she turns on
him during the battle the kylo Ren
monologue about killing the past is
advice he gives to raid to help her
become who she was meant to be
maybe Snoke gives her a little force
push along the side and they all unite
to kill Luke officially making him the
last Jedi Oh
pretty dark right before you say that
the Star Wars universe would never go in
that direction well hate to break it to
you but it already has granted this is
no longer canon but in the novel
sacrifice which is part of the Star Wars
legacy the fourth series the son of Han
and Leia
Jason solo kills his sister's Jedi
Master Mara Jade Skywalker so what you
have is a young solo killing an older
Skywalker who also happens to be his
sister's Jedi teacher sound familiar
it's already happened in the extended
universe once now all the pieces are in
place to make it happen in the movies
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts ever wonder about the
economic ramifications of blowing up the
Death Star what it would do to the
entire galaxy are the rebels truly doing
a good thing here well then click the
Box to the left and hey here's the
subscribe button remember when you see
Star Wars the last Jedi and that ending
looks a little bit familiar remember
that
we made we shook on it or at least we
both pointed our hands at the screen and
did a shaking motion on it so make sure
you hold up your end of the bargain and
come back and force push that subscribe
button now if you'll excuse me I need to
go wait in line for the new movie
because it is coming out soon and I want
to be the first to see how right I am
hopefully fingers crossed